Let's discuss more about
the Bayesian Detection Rate.
We can use the base
theorem to expand this.
And we got this formula here P(I) is
the prior probability of attacks.
Meaning this is the probability of
intrusion evidences in the data.
An intuitive example is that on
a typical day, what's the percentage
of packets that contain intrusion
activities in our network.
There's an interesting phenomenon
about Bayesian detection rate
called the base-rate fallacy.
Even if the false alarm rate is very
low, as long as it is not zero, then
the Bayesian detection rate is still low
even if the base rate is also very low.
For example,
using the formula in the previous slide,
if we plug in these numbers,
meaning the detachment rate is 100%,
false alarm rate is 10 to the -5,
and the base rate is
2 times 10 to the -5, then
the Bayesian Detection Rate is only 66%.
In other words, one-third of the time
when the ideas produces an alert,
there is no intrusion.
If you look at these
numbers more carefully,
100% detection rate is perfect.
False alarm rate of 10
to the -5 is also great.
This is not 0, but is very, very low.
So you may ask,
is this low base rate realistic?
This is 2 x 10 to the -5.
It depends on where do you
measure the base rate.
For example, if you measure base rate at
the network packet level meaning that,
the number of packets that
contain intrusion activities
which can be hundreds or thousands to
a total number of packets in the network
which can be tens and
hundreds of millions.
Then this base-rate can
be quite realistic.
So the base-rate falicy says that, as
long as the false alarm rates' not zero,
then when the IDS produces an alert
the probability that an intrusion
has actually occurred is also low.
So how do we address this problem?
We can reduce the false alarm rate
to be zero, or as much as possible.
In fact, that's what the vendors
of IDS have been trying to do.
Or we can deploy the IDS
to the appropriate layer so
that, at that layer,
the base rate is sufficiently high.
Modern day ideas use a heirarchal
architecture to achieve this.
We can also use multiple
independent models.
This is similar to medical diagnosis
where multiple tests are used to
reduce the overall false positive rate
and increase the base indication rate.